you know said late last night and some
guy came up to me I saw you on Fox &
Friends this morning his Gretchen is
cute in person as she is on T and what
did you answer America George exchanges
Lerner today beautiful dress you look
wonderful
how are you look wonderful Gretchen very
very beautiful dress that a great color
and summery Gretchen's beautiful
beautiful you look beautiful estate
Bryan can you tell Gretchen she is
definitely winning today she looks
amazing Wow and no it's not because Fox
& Friends is too hot but Gretchen is
really too hot blame her then skirts
Gretchen I guess what you're wearing
right now the skirt might cause some pro
not be advisable for the year Gretchen
is gonna ride the mechanical mole live
from our snowy paws a lot of viewers are
concerned that I'm going to have the
skirt on when I do it I'm not sure but
concerned that's interesting work in the
next two minutes will Laura Ingram be
able to change outfits because she cut
has come to the studio dressed
identically to Gretchen thinking all
women should be reading bra stories
right men are experts have you learn
that at broadcasting knowing bra yeah
bras stories defer to the babes under
waxing hurt don't look at me for that
we'll try that on an upcoming episode of
Fox and Friends do you like on one of my
suits or a male masseuse just so I know
oh my god not on TV not gonna you know
you know when I go through ok or do you
like to correct yourself on that other
talking point about men being dominant
oh we don't have any time
we're running over and over okay cuz hrs
on the phone because you called me a
skirt yeah the other symbologies yeah I
got to read that manual again I'll bring
it to your office right after the show
it was the only sexist person that came
on here and made you laugh all right
other than sit next to you every day
right that's chill I'm not [ __ ] them
but I'm put em on I'm having fun with
your just a just sexist
yes okay I just finished yes just in
time I think we should read the
headlines I think it's just you okay